[Alkış]
Merhaba herkese hoş geldiniz
sıcak bir Antalya günü Umarım
eğleneceğiniz bir hikaye anlatacağım
size aslında bir gerçek bir hayalin
gerçek
olması değişimin kendisi Aslında şehirde
nasıl hareket ettiğimizin yeni Çağla
nasıl değişeceğini Aslında ön aak
izlerini burada göreceksiniz Eğir karın
kurucusuyum ben ismim Eray altunbozar
elektrikli otonom bir Çan araba yapan
firmayız arkada gördüğünüz fotoğraf
Aslında ulaşımın yeni çağını temsil
ediyor ama nerede bunlar yani uçan
arabalar Nerede bu geleceğin
e göstergeleri olan teknolojiler vardı
Jet killeri hepiniz bilirsiniz
birçoğunuz bilirsiniz Bunlardan bazıları
aslında burada işlenmişti Eee
Ama bu teknolojiyi kurgulayan
insanların veya
toplumun beklediği bazı değişimler Vardı
Hepsi Burada listeli iletişim bugün cep
telefonunuzdan bir tuşa basarak
karşınızdaki dünyanın neresinde olursa
olsun Onunla yüz yüze görüşebiliyor 20
yıl önce bunu hayal etmek pek mümkün
değildi değil mi şimdi çok kolay bir
tanesi internet bilgiye ulaşım bugün
parmaklarınızın ucunda her şeyi
yapabilirsiniz uçan araba bile yeter ki
nerede arayacağınız bilin ama hepsi
internette bir tanesi Yapay Zeka otonomi
otonomi geldikten sonra şimdi elektrikli
arabalar geliyor değil mi Fabrikalar
endüstri 4.0 her şey kolaylaşıyor
otonomi de geldi ama uçan arabalar
nerede Niye gelmiyor herkes bunu soruyor
Bana da soruyorlar Niye yapamıyorsunuz
ya o kadar kolay değil diyorum ama
aslında teknoloji son 45 yıldır bunu
yapmaya Müsait bir seviyeye yeni geldi
biz onu yapan firmalardan biri olma
şansına Nail
olduk Peki bu kadar kolay olacak mı
gerçekten veya niye ihtiyacımız var
İşte bizim Uçan arabalara ihtiyacımız bu
arkadaki fotoğraftan doğuyor belki
biliniz bilir tanıyınız var mı
fotoğraftakinin kim olduğunu varsa
söyleyebilir Tamam doğru Henry Ford
büyük hry Ford arkasındaki de model
dünyayı değiştiren araba bugün bu
konuşmayı yapmamın da nedeni o h for
1908 yılında bu arabayı çıkarttı ilk
arabası değild ik arabası 1 arabasını
beceremedi para bulamadı parasız kaldı
ama bir şekilde tarihi önünü açtı ve bu
arabayı herkesin satın alabileceği bir
fiyatta yaptı yıl
1908'de New York times'ın ünlü Tim
Sare'nin fotoğrafını görüyorsunuz çok
güzel değil mi trafik Yok gayet sakin
Peki 20 yıl soru ne oldu biliyor musunuz
o model T üretildikten sonra yaklaşık 20
milyon 18 20 milyon arası satış yaptı
bugüne kadar hiçbir araba firması bu
adeti ulaşamadı bildiğiniz bütün
modeller dahil 1928'de üretimi bitmiş
bir araba hala Rekorlar listesinde en
yukarıda ve arabanın üretimi bittiği
zaman işte Times Square hali buydu ve o
gün bugün de Maalesef bu fotoğraf pek
değişmedi ve hep bana şu soru geliyor ya
nasıl yapacaksınız kanun yok kural yok
Hava Yolları yok
teknoloji her zaman peşine kanunları
takıyor önce kanunlar gelmiyor önce
teknoloji teknoloji her zaman
regülasyonları önünü açıyor bakın o
zamanlarda regülasyon yoktu trafik
polisi yoktu trafik ışığı yoktu sigorta
yoktu sürüş belgesi yoktu arabalarla
ilgili bir standart yoktu yol yoktu
hiçbir şey yoktu ama herkesin
ulaşabileceği bir Teknolojik ürün
hepimizin hayatını belki de sonsuza
kadar
değiştirdi
Ve sonunda bu tabloya geldik şehirler
büyüyor bugün 4 milyar insan yaşıyor 6
milyara çıkacağız 2050'de trafik daha da
kötü bir hale gelecek bunun ekonomik
zararı ise çok büyük ve oluşan karbon
emisyonun % 45'i bizim taşımacılığı
yaparken oluşuyor Bunun önüne geçmek
için bir çare bulmalıydı Biz de aslında
bunu yapmak için elimizden geleni
yapıyoruz daha hızlı Sürdürülebilir bir
ulaşım mümkün
M Evet aslında mümkün Bu benim evim
Eee genellikle İstanbul'un bir ucundan
bir ucuna gidiyorum ve yaklaşık en az
bir saat sürüyor şimdi bu soruyu burada
Sormak istemiyorum ama İstanbul'da
sorduğum zaman buraya gelmek için Kim
Bir saatten fazla zaman harcadı dediğim
zaman genelde izleyicilerin % isi
ellerini kaldırıyorlar Eee Peki bunu 7
dakikaya 5 dakikaya 4 dakikaya
düşürebilmek
işte gelen
bu bunu nasıl yapıyoruz şu videoyla
[Müzik]
izleyelim
ne bonsu
var Evet bu izlediğiniz 2 yıl önceki bir
ya da ikinci uçuşumuz özellikle onu
koymak istedim Çünkü 2 yıldır Aslında
uçuyor Şimdi de insanlı uçuşları
Hazırlanıyoruz çok az kaldı Peki aircar
nedir Evet otonom neden az önce
bahsettim buna mümkün elektrikli
arabalar otonom gidebiliyorlar Biz de
gidebiliyoruz havada biraz daha kolay
problem iki kişi taşıyor Çünkü taksi
kullanıcıları genellikle taksideki
yolcular bir iki kişi arasında oluyor bu
da taksi olarak hizmet verecek üzgünüm
bugün satın alamayacaksınız Belki çok
regülasyon buna izin vermeyecek ilk
etapta saatte 120 kilometreyle gidiyor
ki şehir içi ulaşımda Bu gayet yeterli
ve 2026 da piyasaya çıkmasını
planlıyoruz Aslında tüm dünya uçan
arabaların o tarihlerde piyasada
olmasını bekliyor Eee o zaman da
yaklaşık şehir içinde 100 kilometre Bir
menzile ulaşabiliyor olacağız Peki
nerelere inecek Bu da çok gelen bir soru
işte bu portlara Bunlar bizim
tasarladığımız elektrikli arabalarla
aynı şarj altyapısını kullandığımız
Sürdürülebilir Güneş panellerinden
enerjiyi alabildiğimiz bir nebze olsun
Eee elektriğimizi oradan sağladığımız
sistemler şehrin birçok noktasında
bunların olduğunu düşünün aynı benzin
istasyonları gibi veya şarj istasyonları
gibi Bunlar zamanla yayılacak noktadan
noktaya İstediğiniz zaman mobil
aplikasyonunu da eir carı çağıracaksın
ve bir noktadan bir noktaya gideceksiniz
trafiğin yoğun olduğu yerlerde özellikle
başlayacak Türkiye'de mesela İstanbul
ilk başlayacağımız yer Ondan sonra da e
ilerleyecek ve diğer büyük şehirlere de
yayılacak ancak Evet satın
alamayacaksınız söylemiştim maalesef
E peki regülasyonlar ne
durumda dünyada uçan hava araçlarını
regüle eden iki kurum var bir tanesi
federal aviation administration
Amerika'nın Havacılık Kurumu bir tanesi
de Avrupa'nın European aviation safety
Agency Air kı Ben kurduktan Bir ay sonra
faa bununla ilgili bir regülasyon
yayınladı bu araçların Nasıl sertifika
olacağı ile ilgili bir Guide yayınladı
arkadan easa geldi nasa'da Her zamanki
gibi bir şey uçuyorsa işin peşinde O da
bu konunun ilerlemesi için ve Hava
Yollarının çizilmesi için farklı
partnerlik yapıyor Biz de zaman zaman
kendileriyle görüşüyoruz bu
konuda Peki Projeksiyon ne bu bizim
projeksiyon umuz değil Uçan arabalarla
ilgili çalışan firmaların yaptığı
projeksiyon Eee 2030 yılında 8 şehirde
olması planlanıyor Biz de İstanbul bu
şehirlerden birisi o olsun diye canla
başla çalışıyoruz bunu söyleyebilirim
2040 yılında 33 şehir ve ondan sonra da
artık bütün büyük şehirlere En az 1
milyon insanın yaşadığı şehirlerden daha
da aşağı doğru giderek Hayatımızın her
günlük kısmına girecek ve 2,5 milyon
adetlik bir projeksiyon var havacılık
hiçbir zaman bu kadar büyük üretim
yapmadı bu otomobile biraz daha yakın
bir konu olacak Eğir karında Aslında e
Eğir kar olarak yap çalıştığımız
konulardan birisi
bu diyorum ve size teşekkür ediyorum
geleceğimizde taşımacılık Çan arabalarla
Eğir karlarla böyle olacak Sağ olun
dinlediğiniz
için